uh many
films out there
showing new techniques
uh from different teachers and as i've
said many times
everybody even though they're doing
aikido
shows uh a diff and
a different ikea the techniques are the
same but their body
postures
their mannerisms
the way they talk about techniques
we all
vary in
how we set
so i'd like to do a little bit of an
analogy really
i like analogies
those of us who drive on the motorways
let's say we're all going the same way
as hundreds of thousands of other people
and as we're going on the same motorway
even though the same motorway
cars vans buses
all these motor vehicles
going
a majority of them at the weekends will
be going to the same place or same
area and perhaps on holiday
or or a set venue
in the cars if there's several people
they'll be talking about
where they're going what they're looking
forward to
and uh out of those thousands of people
going all in the same direction
there may be hundreds it could be
thousands going let's say to the
sea
and they'll be located in different
areas but they all go for one thing
that's the they're going
for a break
and they're going to their chosen
specific
county
in the country
but the conversations
may be similar
but they won't be the same
and to me that's really how aikido in
daily life is
the techniques were all the same that we
know it doesn't matter what style you do
of aikido
and let's face it there's
there's more
styles out there now then
i don't think they have names
they mainly come under
flowing
shots again sorry
tamiki style yoshinkan style
and
all the various names that you'll see
people choose for their clubs their
organizations
and they've all got little tweaks
but they're all going in the same
direction aren't they they're all doing
aikido
many people tell me i'm wrong in the way
i'm thinking about my aikido it's
because their worth thinking is totally
different
if you ask them um
what is a shomenuchi
immobilization first technique
they'll all say ichio
four directional throw or four
directional cut they'll also shia laggy
so you see the forms and the techniques
are the same
we just talked about them differently
and um
one of the big criterias i'd like to
talk about is we must
as individuals be individuals
i spent far too long
trying to copy exactly what cytosense it
was doing
it is this the fault perhaps it is
perhaps it's not
the japanese they're great copiers
and when
you're in a japanese dojo
the sense they won't really say much
they'll show you it they might show you
a few times they may say a few words but
mainly they're expecting you to copy
you see if you copy
exactly the senses movements
to the finest vice detail
no sense he did say it's the fine detail
that makes the technique
he didn't say that you had to have
spiritual understanding
perhaps it's because he left that to the
individual he left that trust to
decide
what path we would take
in our spiritual quest
some of you may be religious
i never get to talk to really people
about their religion
and most people i've met they don't
really have a religion now
they don't like to seem to mix it with
aikido
meditation is coming up a lot more
nowadays now pairs that we're going more
towards the meditative state
to understand aikido but i think it's
more to do with understanding ourselves
so let me backtrack a little
we're all on the motorway we're all
going the same way but we're talking
about different aspects different things
and that's what i want you to consider
in your aikido
copy
try to be exact
but work out
i
are you happy with that
most of you won't be happy because
you'll be trying to perfect
what you see the teacher do the person
better than you you'll be trying to
mimic them
and be like them
and that's really the japanese way of
teaching
but when you come off the mat you start
to have time to think
you the the individual like in my case
tony
i go off the tatami
and i start thinking about my practice
was it good was it bad
and i start to look
for ideas sometimes we we grasp things
there's many things in aikido
that you have to add to make it work for
you
that you might not be realizing
you might all be going the same way down
the same motorway by doing the same
techniques
but something is not working for you and
for that you need to
find out what you
that the human being the individual
is doing wrong
many times you're trying too hard
by trying too hard that means you're
using strength
you're using the word want
you want to do it
perhaps too much
trying
trying too hard
if you don't try at all will it work
well you can't afford to take that
chance can you
but my aikido developed more when i
started looking at what i wasn't doing
rather than what i was doing
so you have to start thinking well if i
enter strongly towards the person
that's me being forceful in the
technique in the attack with me being
forceful
so how can i go forward and not be
it depends on your attitude if you take
the want out of it and you just do the
action
you're not sending out a wave to the
the other person that you want to do it
you want to come in
perhaps by them
being difficult on the nikki no to go
all the way down
maybe an inbuilt
desire for them to survive because you
sent the message out that you wanted to
achieve that ikea
if you didn't send the message out but
you just done the action
the action would be empty of thought
and i find that this works better
you can escape the technique
if you're
open
to
sensing
and finding searching
than if you know the technique
technically and it's like a b c
and you're driven in that
that direction
to perform it and perfect it and this is
why you get stuck this is why you get
blocks and this is why okay if they wish
to resist they can
many schools they tell you not to exist
and flow with it so those people will
never find out if if there was a going
to be a block
because the uk's agreeing to blend and
help narghay out to perform the
technique to their best ability
so they don't really
on the plus side they don't really need
want but being a human being
one is more likely a natural
ingredient that's in
the person's mind without them even
thinking aggressively
so
look at what
when you look at films or anything watch
the different senses
watch their mannerisms
and then think
well if i watch myself what mannerisms
have i got do i lean do i tip my head
do i sort of look the other way when i
tell me
the person's face do i not look at them
explore who you are
and then look at the teachers if you can
just keep repeating the same thing just
keep rewinding it if you can the same
technique over and over
see how smooth they're escaping where
they're escaping how they're escaping
they may be dissolving
as a teacher
it's a lot different than being
the student the student tries too hard
the teacher is demonstrating and is
already
mentally much higher
in
status than when you're a student when
you're student you're trying to be the
best when you're a teacher out there
demonstrating you're supposed to be the
best so this aura this expansion
is naturally there
okay so i hope these words are not just
mumbo jumbo and they help you to
consider
some of the things that i've said
thank you for your time